AJA: Today, I'm
going to show you
how to upload files to Google
Cloud Storage with Ruby.
Here's the file
I want to upload.
I'm using the Google
Cloud Storage gem.
To use the gem, you need a
project and a service account
key.
Here's my project, and I created
my service account key earlier.
I'll be uploading via IRB.
First, I require Google Cloud
and connect to my project.
Now I create a storage object.
Cloud storage calls
groups of files buckets,
so I need to create a bucket.
Now I can upload my file
by calling creat file
in the bucket and passing it
the source and destination
filenames.
It's that simple.
To verify that the file
got uploaded correctly,
I can use the console.
And there's the
picture I uploaded.
I hope you found this helpful.